depuis quelques jours on assiste à une
vague de dénonciations sur les réseaux
sociaux des allégations de harcèlement
sexuel de racisme entre autres et les
entreprises associées aux personnalités
visées n'ont pas tardé à couper les
biens on pense à marie pier morin les
entreprises bon look bloch lingerie bio
et qui bêlent l'ont fait on va faire le
point avec arnaud granata il est
président du média spécialisé infopresse
qui couvre le monde du marketing et de
la publicité bonsoir monsieur granata
bonsoir ça a été et presque immédiat la
réaction des entreprises les grandes
marques donc non non pas de pardon non
puis vous savez ça va de plus en plus
vite
on l'a vu avec marie pierre morin ça a
pris quelques heures pour que les
marques se désengage donc elle était
porte parole vous l'avez dit de
plusieurs grandes grandes entreprises
les marques ont peur elles ont peur pour
leur réputation parce qu'elles savent
que ça peut avoir un impact économique
très fort sur sur leur vente est
finalement aussi sur ce qu'on va dire
d'elle dans l'est dans les médias mais
pourquoi ça a été si rapide quelques
heures à peine en plus ce sont des
allégations la wii mais marie-pier morin
a pris la parole et elle a fait d'une
certaine façon une forme de mea culpa
elle a dit qu'elle se retirait aussi de
mettet une pause en tout cas sur sa sur
sa vie professionnelle
donc c'est sûr qu'à partir du moment où
elle a pris la parole les marques n'ont
pas vraiment eu le choix de réagir
je vous dirais que ce qu'on a vu dans
les dernières années avec toute cette
vague du mit tout c'est que les marques
sont plus en plus frileuses à la
célébrité s'associer en tout cas une
célébrité ça peut être à double
tranchant ça peut aider les ventes
quand ça va bien et quand il ya un bris
prestation est bien là ça peut vraiment
avoir un effet très négatif sur sur ces
mêmes ventes
ben il ya une longue liste d'entreprises
effectivement qui ont décidé de couper
les liens
ils y arriveront par contre qu'il n'a
pas pris position pourquoi est-ce que ça
peut leur nuire d'attendre ça pourrait
leur nuire après c'est une grande marque
internationale je pense que les marques
qui ont réagi c'est aussi pour la
plupart en tout cas des marques et est
très ancré ici au québec je serais
curieux de voir ce qui va se passer avec
les blancs mais je peux vous garantir
que j'imagine que c'est une question de
temps avant qu'ils n'aient avant qu'il
ne réagisse oui
ça peut falloir combien me combien ça
coûte à une entreprise d'accorder comme
ça des contrats de publicité à une
vedette monsieur granata c'est vraiment
géométrie variable ça dépend de la
grandeur de la marque ça dépend aussi de
la du type de personnalité mais ça peut
être plusieurs centaines de milliers de
dollars dépendamment du type de marque
et de personnalités et forcément c'est
un revenu important pour les porte
paroles mais ça génère aussi beaucoup de
ventes et c'est la raison pour laquelle
il ya de nombreuses entreprises qui font
appel à des porte parole oui ben
justement c'est quoi l'impact économique
là pour une entreprise
évidemment lorsqu'il ya un faux pas de
l'apport d'un porte parole on comprend
l'impact son image sur les ventes
potentielles mais ce sont des
investissements qu une entreprise fait
dans un artiste oui absolument si on
prend le cas de marie pier morin sur son
compte instagram il y avait de
nombreuses publications sponsorisés
commandité donc par ces par ces grandes
marques elle représente tout c'est
toutes ces photos ont été retirés donc
les campagnes s'arrête si vous voulez
d'une façon assez abrupte donc c'est sûr
que les marques ont ont perdu en valeur
médias mais par contre une chose est
sûre c'est que je pense que sur le sur
le long terme sur le moyen terme à tout
le moins
elles vont elles vont gagner parce qu'il
n'y a rien de pire pour une entreprise
que se retrouver au coeur d'une d'une
controverse et vous savez les
consommateurs sont très prompts à réagir
sur les médias sociaux
très prompts aussi à boycotter on l'a vu
dans les dents les dernières années
certaines entreprises et certains
produits
oui mais là je pensais justement
certains certains dossiers du passé je
pense à tiger woods par exemple vedettes
qui ont fait des faux pas qui ont été
accusés s'est passé dans certains cas de
rétablir la réputation redorer l'image
au point de récupérer des contrats de
publicité
oui vous savez particulièrement aux
états unis il ya des ce qu'on appelle
les spin doctor qui travaillent très
fort ces docteurs de l'image pour
redorer l'image de personnalités qui ont
eu des ennuis avec avec la justice ou
avec les avec les médias je pense que ça
prend du temps
par contre je crois que depuis le
mouvement mis tout on voit qu'il ya des
choses qui qui ont pu leur place
aujourd'hui et aimer les marques et les
entreprises et les médias sont beaucoup
plus sont beaucoup plus sensibles dont
je pense que ça va prendre du temps
avant qu'on voit certaines personnalités
réapparaître
sur le radar médiatique ben quand une
entreprise décide justement d'avoir
recours aux services d'une célébrité
d'une vedette
j'imagine qu'ils font leurs devoirs
qu'elle sorte banque est foncée l'elysée
crème les réseaux sociaux ils vont quand
même pas jusqu'à rencontrer les
l'entourage qu'est-ce qu'ils font
précisément mais je pense que la
première chose c'est c'est les valeurs
c'est ce que cette personne représente
c'est ce qu'elle est capable de vendre
la marque
et puis utilement est ce qu'il ya eu des
cas dans le passé deux choses qui
pourraient être qui pourrait être
dommageable pour l'entreprise
mais vous savez toutes ces entreprises
ont aussi des contrats qui leur
permettent de se retirer à n'importe
quel moment à ses prédécesseurs
oui ça absolument donc surtout des
entreprises vous savez aujourd'hui
qu'ils mettent de l'avant beaucoup les
valeurs sociales qui qui essaye d'être
de bons citoyens corporatifs
donc elles ne peuvent plus prendre le
risque d'attendre et d'attendre que
quétier dès qu'ils aient des
conséquences assez graves qui peuvent
être assez grad sur leur réputation
monsieur granata merci beaucoup d'avoir
été là merci à vous